bonjour on se retrouve pour cet épisode
dans ma cuisine puisque on va parler
aujourd'hui de plantes cultivées en
particulier celles que l'on mange et que
l'on retrouve dans nos placards de
cuisine
donc j'ai à mes côtés mais beaucoup qui
sort tout droit de mes placards et qui
sont ici remplis de légumineuses en tout
genre et de ce côté ci des fruits et des
légumes que vous avez cendres tous
rencontrés au moins une fois dans votre
vie
donc on a ici des tomates des patates 1
poivron du maïs tous ces aliments on les
connaît depuis longtemps en europe
pourtant ils ne sont pas originaires de
ce continent
alors non je ne vais pas improvisé
devant vous une imitation de maïté on
pas que l'on soit pas capable à quoi bon
jour ni même cuisiner une ratatouille
parce que c'est encore deux saisons n'a
en réalité je me suis dit qu'il serait
intéressant de discuter des aliments que
l'on considère comme acquis et
traditionnel dans nos cuisines et de se
rappeler quelle a été leur cheminement
pour arriver un jour en europe
car si j'ai évoqué l'art à tatouille
juste avant et bien il faut savoir
qu'une certaine époque il n'aurait pas
été possible de cuisiner cela qui tourne
21e siècle un instant et rappelons qu en
europe avant la découverte des amériques
par christophe colomb en 14 192 et
d'autres explorateurs qui ont suivi il
n'était pas question de cuisiner autre
chose que principalement du chou du
navet des endives des radis du pis en
ligne et côté fruits on se concentraient
surtout sur le raisin et bien sûr des
poires et des pommes en quantité du coup
exit les expressions style et comme j'ai
pas la frite ça vaut pas une cacahuète
ça me prend le chou du coup ses fils
aymon cependant ce n'est pas à ce cher
colons que l'on doive une des
découvertes majeures en matière de
plantes à cultiver
je veux bien sûr parler de la pomme de
terre découverte par pizarro lors de la
conquête du pérou la papa comme les
incas l'appelèrent est introduite au
xvième siècle en espagne
longtemps considérés comme impropres à
la consommation et appauvrissant le sol
la pomme de terre fut au départ
consommer uniquement en temps de disette
par les paysans et c'est seulement au
xviiie siècle soit un siècle et demi
après sa découverte que la pomme de
terre fut réellement cultivées en europe
est consommée par les élites
grâce aux recherches de parmentier
prouvant les vertus nutritionnelles de
la plante comme ensuite ne pas évoquer
la tomate
tout comme la pomme de terre il faudra
du temps pour que ce fruit soit
réellement consommés par les
p1 ce fruit a été domestiqué au mexique
puis introduit en europe
au 16ème siècle par les espagnols c'est
durant ce siècle une plante
d'ornementation âge alors il faut
attendre le milieu de dix huitième pour
que l'on consomme enfin ses fruits
considérée jusque-là comme toxiques vous
l'aurez compris en europe avant le 16e
siècle et l'arrivée des plaintes
américaines on ne pouvait pas manger de
pizza de frais de pop com qui sont les
trois aliments qui distingue
véritablement la grandeur de l'homme
moderne du sauvage préhistorique pour
qu'ils aient des pommes de terre des
tomates et bien d'autres plantes dans
nos assiettes et nos jardins aujourd'hui
il a fallu attendre que les hommes
découvrent de nouveaux territoires et a
pris voit ces nouvelles espèces
végétales
il a fallu également des améliorations
technologiques et en particulier la
sélection et croisements en effet la
plupart du temps il a fallu modifier la
plante pour qu'elles s'acclimate à ce
nouveau territoire
dans un précédent épisode on évoquer la
notion d'endémisme qui est rappelons le
la zone d'origine d'une plante à l'état
sauvage pour la pomme de terre par
exemple c'est l'altiplano dupeyron tout
ça nous amène à parler de la notion
d'écosystème qui et vous allez le voir
une notion essentielle pour comprendre
notre rapport au plein de cultiver
aujourd'hui un écosystème c'est un
regroupement de différentes espèces
végétales animales dans un espace donné
ça peut être une forêt un jardin
tropical une steppe un champ de blé un
écosystème n'est donc pas quelque chose
de figé il évolue dans le temps grâce
aux interactions entre toutes les
espèces qui le composent pourquoi parler
de ça eh bien depuis l'apparition de
l'agriculture et en particulier de la
culture de masse qui caractérise notre
époque nous pouvons distinguer deux
cents d'écosystèmes d'un côté les
écosystèmes naturels que l'on appelle en
jargon scientifique généralisée et de
l'autre côté les écosystèmes
artificielle dits spécialisés
alors rassurez vous si ces termes vous
semble complexe les exemples qui vont
suivre devrait clarifier tout ça
reprenons les exemples évoqués plus haut
quelle différence y at il à votre avis
en train jardin tropical et un champ de
blé d'un jardin tropical
il ya une grande diversité de plantes
cultivées un tel jardin copie la
structure et le fonctionnement de
l'écosystème naturel une forêt tropicale
en l'occurrence on dit alors qu'il est
stable parce que si une maladie touche
une des espèces le reste n'en sera pas
affectée il ya une sorte de relais qui
va s'opérer entre les espèces végétales
une sorte de coopération tandis qu'un
chambley d'une seule variété un
écosystème très spécialisés et sa
productivité ne peut être bonne que par
un apport régulier de fertilisants de
pesticides et de pratiques agricoles en
tout genre on dit alors qu'il est
instable car vulnérables résumons plus
un écosystème comprend des espèces
végétales ou animales variées - les
maladies se propagent
d'où sa stabilité qu'on évoquait un peu
avant les mayas l'avait bien compris en
associant dans leurs plantations
le haricot la courge et le maïs il se
trouve que cette culture mixte accroît
fortement le rendement et permet de
maintenir le champ en état de fertilité
al'inverse dans un écosystème très
spécialisés il n'y a aucun recours si un
problème survient au 19e siècle
l'irlande connu une grande famille suite
à un incident climatique les cultures de
pommes de terre furent ravagés
entraînant des troubles sociaux et
politiques qui ont conduit à
l'émigration massive des irlandais vers
les états unis
moralité sur se spécialisant d'une
culture mais qu'on n'a pas de moyens de
défense contre un prédateur d'une
maladie on risque gros
et ça c'est pas seulement propre la
pomme de terre mais ça se vérifie pour
toutes les espèces végétales
un exemple criant c'est celui du café
originaire d'abyssinie il fut dès le
départ planté au yémen puis cultiver un
peu partout en afrique
le café se buvait en orient au xvième
siècle et se répandit en europe à partir
du xviie
ce sont les hollandais qui les premiers
à introduire le café hors de sa zone
d'endémisme et le plante est assez lent
en 16 199 puis un peu plus tard à java
cette culture prospérera fort longtemps
on pourrait même dire que les choses
étaient plutôt bien rodé jusqu en 1869
ou là manque de bol un champignon ruina
les cultures assez lent et s'étendit à
java
résultat ce sont les brésiliens qui
raflèrent le marché du café ainsi que
les antilles françaises et les
hollandais
eh ben il avait dans l'os ses coûts
c'est pourquoi malgré les risques liés à
la monoculture sait-on tourner de plus
en plus vers ce type d'agriculture
pourquoi adopter pour des écosystèmes
artificielle des écosystèmes spécialisé
à notre époque il est certain que la
densité de population humaine est un
facteur clé dans le fonctionnement de
notre agriculture
les modifications apportées à la nature
doivent correspondre des attentes
économiques et évidemment ça a des
répercussions sur les écosystèmes
si on tient vraiment à maintenir ce type
d'agriculture pour avoir un rendement
maximal
eh ben on n'a pas vraiment le choix il
faut choisir entre ces trois options
options numéro un on limite la
croissance de la population option
numéro 2 on accroît le territoire et
donc on va chez le voisin piquer ses
terres c'est alors un peu le retour
dernière option on assume le dérèglement
de l'éco-système et on compense par la
porte de fertilisants on améliore les
techniques et on se concentre sur les
plantes qui ont le meilleur rendement
c'est alors la course à l'innovation
technique et scientifique cette quête du
progrès scientifique
elle s'illustre parfaitement avec les
ogm avant les ogm
l'amélioration des végétaux ne se
faisait que par croisement de deux
individus sélectionnés au sein d'une
même espèce ou même genre avec les ogm
c'est différent on intègre cette fois un
nouveau gène qui est particulièrement
intéressant et qui peut être issu de
n'importe quel être vivant
ça peut être un génie de virus de
bactéries et de champignons d'animal que
l'on transfère dans la plante est une
technique puissante et qu'il ya des
intérêts économiques puissants
eux aussi peuvent libérer linda runs
mais non dénué de risques de dérives
puisque l'humain peut ainsi guider
l'évolution des espèces dans un sens qui
l'intéressent cette vidéo n'a pas pour
thème les ogm mais il est difficile
une vidéo sur les plantes sans évoquer
ce sujet donc si ça vous intéresse je
vous ai mis dans la barre d'infos un
lien dans la documentation et je répond
évidemment à vos commentaires j'ai
longuement insisté sur le terme
écosystèmes savez vous que nous
hébergeons en où l'un des écosystèmes
les plus sophistiqués il s'agit de notre
intestin
de plus en plus d'études scientifiques
sont accessibles au grand public
concernant le lien alimentation santé
bien-être et mettre l'accent sur le
fonctionnement de nos intestins qui sont
dotés de bactéries de microbes
on parle même de flore pour décrire le
microbiote intestinal
tout comme le jardin notre intestin
fonctionne sur la coopération entre
différentes sortes d'organismes s'aidant
mutuellement
là où je voulais en venir avec cette
vidéo c'est que les aliments qu'ils
remplissent nos garde manger ne sont une
évidence d'une coïncidence
il a fallu parfois un temps d'adaptation
non négligeable pour faire entrer une
nouvelle espèce dans nos cuisines
regarder rapidement vos placards et vous
constaterez que la majorité de vos
produits sont le résultat de centaines
voire de milliers d'années de recherches
autour des plantes de sélection
d'amélioration lente des espèces
végétales
cette idée m'a alors traversé l'esprit
le régime alimentaire nos grands-parents
se résume à ce qui poussait dans leur
jardin avec l'industrialisation massive
l'exode rural et l'apparition soudaine
d'une alimentation moderne
nous avons consommé le fruit des
recherches scientifiques que ce soit la
patate frite qui cuit sans huile avec
des angles à 90° le jambon caressant
gras les petits suisses fluo en
parallèle depuis quelques années les
intolérances et autres allergies
alimentaires explose ce que les régimes
dits elle 6-1 détox tente de résoudre
les causes de ces problèmes peuvent être
diverses mais mon idée c'est que si les
populations ont basé leur alimentation
pendant des millénaires sur incertaine
assemblage de plantes c'était peut-être
dû au hasard au départ mais ensuite
parce que ces populations et en
particulier leurs intestins se sont
adaptés à ces plantes
si on ajoute des éléments à notre
alimentation de manière brutale à
l'échelle de quelques générations je
parle pas forcément d'un patates ou des
tomates on a lu ça s'était fait
progressivement
ça peut entraîner des bouleversements
dans notre intestin on sait en effet que
les flore intestinale sont différentes
selon les peuples et même les familles
modifié brusquement l' équilibre
de notre écosystème intérieur à coups de
conservateurs et de maïs transgénique
n'est peut-être pas le meilleur moyen
d'être en bonne santé
si jardin et intestins sont des
écosystèmes et si on veut appliquer le
même raisonnement que faut-il alors
préféré quelque chose de spécialiser ou
de généraliser
c'est à dire d'artificiel ou de naturel
cet épisode est terminé merci à tous de
l'avoir regardé s'il vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à le leak et est elle
partagée est évidemment vous pouvez vous
abonner à la chaîne ça me ferait très
plaisir
alors vous remplissez d'eau lié de l'eau
à ras bord et voulait faire bouillir 2
heures de retard